The first trailer for Glass just dropped reuniting
Unbreakable's Bruce Willis and Samuel L Jackson
and adding Split's James McAvoy to the comic-book
mix.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm breaking down the Glass trailer
for intriguing details and connections you
might have missed.
Notice the purple glow that flashes over the
Universal logo towards the start of the trailer.
That's a nice nod to the colour that's been
associated with our titular character, Glass,
since he first appeared in the movie Unbreakable
back in 2000.
And when we see Elijah aka Mr Glass, Kevin
Wendell Crumb, and David Dunn together in
this scene, each of them is wearing their
signature colour from either Unbreakable or
Split.
Glass is in purple, Dunn is in green (albeit
a very pale one), and Kevin is in yellow.
These colours are also reflected in the design
of the villain and superhero in the first
comic book that a young Elijah was given by
his mother in Unbreakable.
And this colour scheme is also evident in
the comic book store later in the trailer,
where the 'Heroes' section is bathed in green
light, and where the 'Villains' section is
in purple.
As we know from Split, Kevin has 23 separate
personalities which were shown on Kevin's
computer plus a 24th superhuman alter ego
known as The Beast.
And Sarah Paulson's psychiatrist character
Dr Ellie Staple already understands this.
"I have no question, there are two dozen identities."
"I'm Mary Reynolds."
"Por favor, señora."
"We almost got you bro!"
"That live in that body with you."
From the trailer, it looks like we'll get
to see at least three more of Kevin's identities.There's
Mary Reynolds, a Spanish-speaking personality,
and maybe a prankster-type American guy?
Notice also the multiple toothbrushes provided
for Kevin.
One for each of his personalities which is
a subtle call-back to the 23 toothbrushes
Kevin also had in Split.
"But what I am questioning is your belief
that you are something more than human."
Now, that's an interesting parallel between
Dr Staple and Kevin's former psychiatrist
Dr Fletcher who also had her doubts about
whether the Beast was real or not.
"I don't understand."
"He can't be real."
"There must be limits to what a human being
can become."
Of course, we know that the Beast was very
real in Split and it seems like Mr Glass probably
knows that too or perhaps he even had something
to do with Kevin's backstory.
There's an interesting shot of Glass looking
at a comic book where a character is prising
open steel bars in a shot that's very reminiscent
of the end of Split where the Beast tried
to break into the cage that Casey had locked
herself into.
The two wounds on Kevin's torso is another
nice detail calling back to that encounter
when Casey tried to shoot the Beast at point-blank
range.
And Mr Glass actually refers to that moment
from Split with the line/this line/the following
line:
"And yet some of us still don't die with bullets."
Glass is clearly fascinated with the Beast
and wants to meet him
"May I meet the Beast?"
"I hope for your sake that he likes you."
"That sounds like the bad guys teaming up."
I wonder if by "bad guys", Glass is not just
referring to himself and the Beast joining
forces, but he's actually also referring to
The Horde which is the name the news report
gave to Kevin at the end of Split.
"Because of his many personalities, he is
being called...
The Horde."
Remember also in Unbreakable, Glass is interested
in a comic book called Sentryman and the Coalition
of Evil.
And interestingly, some of that cover appears
in the Comic-Con poster art for Glass.
I have a feeling that Mr Glass is planning
to manipulate Kevin for his own ends.
Think back to what his mother said in Unbreakable:
"There's the soldier villain who fights the
hero with his hands... and then there's the
real threat-- the brilliant and evil archenemy...
who fights the hero with his mind."
I think Glass sees himself as the brilliant
genius and Kevin as a useful powerful villain
to serve his needs.
"No way!"
Also key to the story is going to be Casey
who seems to be able to connect with Kevin,
it appears via Hedwig in this scene.
Similar to how she did in Split getting him
to take her to the window in his room and
give her his walkie-talkie.
And returning from Unbreakable are David Dunn's
son and Elijah Prince's mother who could both
hold clues or be keys to understanding how
Dunn and Glass acquired their powers and weaknesses.
It looks like the movie will also revisit
Dunn's kryptonite, water, with him getting
attacked by the Beast possibly knocking him
into a small water tower behind him here?
The shot of the Beast knocking Dunn out of
a building window also reminds me of Unbreakable
when Dunn was pushed over a balcony into a
swimming pool.
Also notice that Dr Staple looks to be rescuing
Dunn by pulling him out of water in this other
shot.
"What do we call you, sir?"
"First name, Mr; last name, Glass."
This is a rather epic way to end the trailer.
And I don't know about you, but those final
lines gave me vibes of Sidney Poitier in the
1960s Oscar-winning film In The Heat Of The
Night.
"What did they call you up there?"
"They call me, Mr Tibbs."
So, what do you think about the Glass trailer?
And did you spot any other interesting details
or do you have any theories about the movie?
Leave your comments and thoughts below and,
if you enjoyed this, a like is really appreciated.
Tap left to check out more of my comic-book
movie videos or tap right for another video
you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!